je ne dénoncerai pas mais je ne veux
plus jamais voir ici on va te faire de
nouveaux papiers d'identité et de
trouver un autre travail
c'est ma soeur on lui apprend à nager
vaut mieux que quelqu'un il a cherché
rogalle va aller la chercher alors je te
présente monsieur s'est déjà vu tu
verras la clandestinité c'est génial et
vit son travail
je suis
que ça
je remarque que tu ne vas pas te d'y
aller de son but s'il te plaît c'est moi
stéphane je jure de servir fidèlement ma
patrie on va faire plein de choses
ensemble
manger dormir et peut-être même poussé
la chansonnette
ils sont en train de bombarder l'hôpital
stéphane n ya pas il faut aller chercher
maintenant mes hommes sont à votre
entière disposition
c'est des gosses
celui qui croyait création action allait
durer trois jours il s'est trompé
m
non non
broulis bras pourquoi vous faites ça
je ne laisse pas de taille
je veux pas crever caire comprend ça va
crever on va se battre jusqu'à la fin
bah
quitte cette ville en parts ou led rien
tout sépare chaque étoile